alors un des principaux événements
marquants en europe en 2015 voir
continuer d'attirer l'attention en 2016
et c'est cette fameuse crise des
migrants en 2015 il ya eu plus d'un
million de personnes qui cherchent
refuge en europe qui ont franchi l'océan
pour se rendre sur les côtes européennes
c'est du jamais vu est-ce que ça va se
poursuivre au même rythme or 2007
probablement pas parce qu'il ya des
mesures qui sont prises par l'europe le
conseil d'europe par exemple offert
récemment de payer jusqu'à un milliard
d'euros à la turquie pour améliorer les
conditions de vie dans les camps de
réfugiés en turquie
c'est la même chose ou liban et en
jordanie
donc il le rap veut faire en sorte que
les gens soient mieux traitées dans ces
camps et qu'il donc qui changent d'idée
qu'ils ne décident plus de venir en
europe par ailleurs il ya aussi l'europe
qui prend des moyens pour traiter plus
rapidement les demandes de réfugiés qui
arrivent aux frontières extérieures de
la zone européenne et de cette manière
on veut accélérer la prise de décision
et renvoyé retourner chez eux ceux qui
n'ont pas accès au statut de réfugié
mais ça fonctionne ça très très mal
comme la gestion générale en europe ce
soit un sujet à suivre de près parce que
la gestion dépendant des pays qui
ferment ou qui ouvrent leurs frontières
en particulier dans l'est de l'europe
pose un grand problème et risque de
devenir une source de divisions au sein
même de l'union européenne